- This is the beauty of Dubai.
It's just because it's a city
where we have all nationalities
of the world, you know?
Everybody has his own
angle, his own world,
his own point of view on a situation.
So, if you bring everybody
in the same place,
we'll see fireworks of creativity.
- [Anna] I'm Anna Devis.
- [Daniel] I'm Daniel Rueda.
- [Anna] Together we are
architects and photographers.
- [Daniel] Our approach is
to play with perspectives
and geometry within an urban landscape.
- [Anna] And as architects,
we travel the world exploring
unseen aspects of buildings
so we can tell stories through the image.
- [Daniel] We are on a
journey to meet with other
like-minded and inspiring
creatives in Dubai.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Anna] Here, we will
meet with spontaneous
content creator, Remy Abouchakra
We meet with Remy to
share artistic approaches
and we'll begin by taking in
a bird's eye view of Dubai.
- [Remy] I'm in Dubai
since three years now,
so a lot of people knows me
here as A French in Dubai.
I do my own content,
I do from photo and video, stop motion.
I pull out that I can take from my camera,
from my phone.
I like to try to find
innovative content everyday.
And to be unique.
I think Dubai's a fantastic
city to create content.
You have a lot of different places.
Because it looks good and
people already experience it.
But you want to try to find a new angle,
actually, to have your own creation.
I don't plan too much
recorded or freestyle shoot.
I play with light, with shape,
with shadows, with motion.
I have this idea, and I go
on the street, I shoot it,
I do a quick edit on my
computer and post it.
- [Daniel] It is this impulsive
style of Remy's photography
that is so interesting to us.
The way his mind works fast
to complete a narrative
for his imagery is fascinating.
I think your pictures are
also very easy to catch.
Very bold, you can really
see what he was looking for.
But at the same time,
we are achieving that
in very different ways.
We are more staged, theatrical.
While he is more fresh
and dynamic and quick.
- The geometry for it is super important.
Because you play a lot with symmetry.
- [Anna] We are architects, so.
- For us it's impossible not
to think about those things.
We like to find places that
has the same kind of pictures
from the same distance,
the same focal length,
and you change those things a little bit.
Maybe add some humor or like a prop.
Or a certain outfit or a
certain perspective or distance.
- [Anna] Everything in
the frame is considered.
We buy paint, wardrobe and props.
Sometimes, even make them
if the image needs it.
(upbeat music)
- [Daniel] Dubai it's really
easy to step back a little bit
and you can take it all in,
how the beautiful design and the facades.
They have a much more
creative spirit in the design.
(soothing electronic music)
Once you get up to the top,
you can see how everything
was so taken care of.
And you can see all the details.
You can see how everything was done
to be beautiful and geometric.
- [Anna] We've seen so many unique aspects
to Dubai's skyline while
visiting with Remy.
It's been eye-opening
learning about his approach
and comparing and collaborating with him.
- [Remy] I think I'm a really hard worker.
I work maybe six days per week.
I really like this city for that.
You get a lot of opportunities,
you can do your own projects,
you can grow very fast.
And I think this is the beauty of it.
Everybody can be a content creator today.
What's a content creator?
It's not just me, it can
be you, it can be you,
it can be anyone.
I don't even know if I will be
a photographer in two years.
And I like that.
- [Anna] It is this
creativity that inspired us
to even create our own
image while in Dubai.
And we'll take Remy's
adventurous thinking home with us
for future projects.
- I'm living the dream, beautiful right?
- (soothing electronic music)